foreign
[Music]
what's up super sexy rejects we are
watching a movie today that has a title
and and
um and that's your intro see on the
other side
okay that's good enough we watch soccer
and Dale Versus Evil and Roxy has never
seen Roxy I never even heard of this
until until I messaged her asking if
you've seen it you said are you making
titles up and now full disclosure what
does the YouTube safe word for this I
took a lot of food gummy stuff when I
saw this when it first came out over a
decade ago all I remembered was going
that was fun can't tell you a single
detail about this movie literally have
no idea how the act one two or three
goes you know they're three acts though
I am assuming it's a movie yeah maybe
it's a 10 hack structure you see this is
like five out of five stars and I've
never heard of it when you texted it to
me I thought it was part of the Ash
versus evil dead franchise
hey can you ask them to leave a like
yeah guys don't forget it's very
important like comment subscribe tell
your friends so we get more sexy Rejects
what's the voice I don't know are you
doing a koi impression maybe no I'd have
to talk way quicker than that yeah and
you have to yell like comment subscribe
leave all the things yeah you're doing
the face at least he really does he gets
big
in the face and also uh yeah thanks for
clarifying yeah and uh also uh fully
Reaction watch the lock screen with your
own coffee those are the sexy rejects
the patriots the patriots yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah that's a good point but you
should all be patrons by now because
that's where the sexy people are yeah
listen to the woman with the hair that's
an inside joke I do have hair how's it
doing today not ideal it's good enough
that's how you compliment people when we
were starting I was fixing my hair and
he said you're fine and then he said
look you look like a waitress
which is
right now
listen this intro is going on way too
long no it's not this is what the people
want this is what the people want yep
try editing a video with her and koi
it's her total blast that's what I hear
I hear we're a great pair are you sure
we should be doing this this is still a
crime scene stack up Billy it's called
investigative journalism for a reason
what do you say Billy want a Peabody
Award look great up on you oh no
foreign
not the slightest bit familiar
we wouldn't have thought to bring this
okay I I stand correctly you
[Music]
hey guys what's going on we forgot the
beer
that would suck
can I help you
hey Chad do we need more bugs
Chad they're all douchebags
kind of looks like John if he gain like
100 pounds pickled eggs six pounder
you oh hot dog Tucker have you ever seen
anything like that in your life there's
nothing so special about them the noise
in my ear pickled eggs you gotta have
some faith in yourself man girls can
smell fear now come on you are a good
looking man more or less
[Laughter]
what's the worst that can happen
oh my God your childhood fears get
activated you're right tuck
I'm gonna do it all right I'm gonna do
it right now you gotta chew and swallow
my dude smile on left okay
all right why does she have that
Grim Reaper oh what a dumbass you guys
uh
going camping
look we don't want any trouble all right
so just oh
poor guy John does not have that problem
this is that's a giver giv apostrophe ER
you know what your problem is you got an
inferiority complex
no I don't yeah yeah nope
let me tell you something life is short
you got to go after what you want sure
sure as hell ain't gonna just fall right
in your lap that's true I reckon oh [__]
what are you doing
oh what a dumbass we used to call these
Road sodas
oh no
[Music]
get up my hand is stuck it
yeah
howdy officer
we are headed to our vacation home up by
Morris Lake me and Dale here we're gonna
go fix her up maybe do a little fishing
do a little fishing
bigger little man time might do them
some good
three nothing
up there but pain is suffering on a
scale you can't even imagine
oh okay that must be the evil you got
broken turn signal oh yes sir get that
fixed
that was very helpful
yes as they are PSA drinking and driving
is no joke that's true that's very true
but riding in the passenger seat having
a beer oh harmless
we're a little more okay with it
I really uh like the inverse on these
two of how they present them like their
typical hillbilly villains and then your
spot out there just soft guys
did they establish what the real are
they Brothers maybe just besties
whoever used to live here must have been
a an archaeologist or something yeah
yeah
look at this must have been a real News
Junkie too
I'm a sort of real news
by three get two free no expiration date
all right no experience dreams really do
come true
oh my God
oh holy moly fix that yeah that's a good
idea
you can get off of me now they have such
cute energy I know and you want to hear
a real story yep it was 20 years ago
today
[Laughter]
that's
so dumb
[Music]
hey man what the hell are you doing yeah
there's a logic too
foreign
that is the color green of the film
[Music]
oh
only one person lived to tell this story
who's the one
the killer who wants to go
skinny-dipping
I do let's go
all right oh maybe the police officer
was the one person I care taking this
mystery very serious I appreciate that
you asked you know you can drop the act
now what act
like you're better than everyone else
you are better than everyone else
you and I Ali are Cut From a Different
Cloth what is happening she's done
nothing to show this I know I think he's
just really attracted her
it's a good thing it lowers my
inhibitions well
why
why stop
you're gross
let's talk about this later I'm gonna go
catch up with everyone
I'm gonna catch up with everyone you
don't find him attractive uh just for
some reason no but I do know 50 of him
I think we should go check it out
good luck
I'm glad we chose this movie
it's a good movie for this moment right
here have you seen 30 Rock
oh [__]
they look painful is she okay you do not
yell out my name well you were being a
Peeping Tom
you were hopeless do you know that
you're hopeless no I think that's
respectful
she don't push your woke agendas
during my Tucker and Dale Versus Evil
good point good point go vocal broke
respectful where'd you go Chuck
oh
he is a sweetheart
he got it
I don't know how they just keep
mistakenly we got your friend it's a gun
they got Allison this guy is
your friend while the hell are they
running away
this is great
getting misinterpreted such a funny idea
or Hillbillies heavily from the store
lesson
it's time to rise to the occasion man
what you gonna do Chad
they captured her by canoe
bandana see
yeah
more bandages I'm wearing a bandage
right now I could mess with a bandana
imagine I've said reject on it that'd be
sick product placement product placement
income
I think I should ask pancakes
poor guy poor guy honestly I could mess
with some pancakes I know and a bandana
it's just a cabin it doesn't mean
they're psycho Killers Psycho Killer
then why don't you go in there and talk
to them all right maybe I will is he new
here
I can recognize him
he's got a name tag yeah
he works here
oh oh you don't remember okay uh well
uh Man Tucker I mean uh uh I and Tuck
[Music]
Tucker and I brung you here
that's my dog drinkers he he looks mean
but he's just a big old marshmallow you
can just pet him around the nose
it's drooling I know
Tucker just bought this place and uh you
know
I'm sure it doesn't look like much to a
high class girl like you oh
but uh anyway
you should relax and rest okay he is so
cute what's your name
it's tail Ducker tell him my name
do you guys have anything to to do
around here
do you like board games
what kind do you have
yes come on four to seven no wait
you went too early
one two three do you go one two three
then go Rock Paper Scissors Shoot oh
it's not not bad that's cut that
Bostonian [__] out of here man
La rock paper scissors that's where you
go shooting on scissors yeah whatever we
need to watch the movie it's not a coin
Roxy reaction better much you know me
yeah
sending in the guy we don't know so
something's gonna happen
Mitchell parts
so he has a really good lock on
perspective with switching between them
all right
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right
oh no
I knew he was gonna die I knew it
these kills are actually pretty good
does it be yeah it's already released
in that moment he realized he knew who
was the fifth president of the United
States oh that's too easy that's James
Monroe
God you were right again
did you know that obviously not
I barely made it past the third grade
hey this
[Music]
is a lot to say yeah keep telling
yourself that I'm getting my Bachelor's
degree in Psychology oh oh so what kind
of work would you do with that
so many of the major problems and
conflicts in the world are caused by a
lack of communication you know yeah
hey hey
oh my God Tucker what happened to your
face I sought into a business
why well I didn't do it on purpose why
wow
we came out here to work oh no it should
arrived playing stupid board games
hey how about I come over here and I
pull those stingers out of your face and
then I'll help you with whatever you
want all right I'd block that thank you
okay I've never been stung by a bee no
they it sucks
it's not real wood
plastic
just leave
let's go outside and knock on somewhere
we'll go find a friends you should relax
Tucker and Dale are on the case I get
that right Tucker
yeah do you think he saw that the friend
died no I want to let Tucker do most of
the talking anyway he can win over just
about anybody can't you Tucker real
people person
okay here we go
me neither he's amazing he's so good you
[__] quit it with this thing okay it
doesn't work out here oh we gotta get to
the road why did he break cause Chad's
the worst survival of the fish
oh God
whoa not bad what are you doing man
that's my whole face
somebody's coming oh [__]
oh [__] you left the ax
and they're hiding behind
a fairies
it's a hatchet
Pilots kid
College hey College counts
Carla's kids
laughs
maybe we could leave them a note in case
they come back careful I'm gonna have to
etch it in
probably took them an hour I know I feel
like it took a very very long time
we got your friend you think that girl
is hot yeah she said that problems come
down to lack of communication and that's
all that's happening in this movie hello
hello
what huh what what's this outfit not a
waitress tell you that much where did
she find it I don't know oh yeah good
question you mind if I help what no no
no no no it's not work for a pretty for
a girl like you that's oh whoa I grew up
on a farm it's either help out or get
out oh man she's perfect
you know what I mean for what you know
just a perfect human appreciate yeah we
need more for them perfect for Dale I'm
just curious about where these pants
came from
oh those are so scary
yeah sick he's making her dig her own
grave
this movie's really kind of clever it's
very clever I'm shocked I haven't heard
of this no
oh good looking friends are here hey
[Music]
oh no
oh
no that's two people death by like
dagger through them
oh well it's pretty obvious it's gonna
happen to this guy
he just died right in there
foreign
oh my God oh my God
[Laughter]
I love the way that was shot it just
like straight open to another of God
what happened to you
some kid
you talked himself right into the wood
chipper let's head first right into the
wood chipper
it looked like it might have been one of
the colors because what the hell
happened to her
she got knocked down fell into the
[__] hole right next to me is that
your blood no it's college kid blood
college kid let's come running out of
nowhere in spirit cell spectrums
holy crap
I know what this is what
this is a side pack oh my God
you're coming out here and they're
killing themselves all over the woods oh
my God that makes so much sense
sharp objects
I think they're trying to kill her too
that's why they acted so funny after we
saved her because they want her dead oh
my God we'll go to the police
it's a good idea Dale oh Heidi Ho
officer we've had a doozy of a day there
we were minding our own business just
doing some chores around the house when
kids started killing themselves all over
my property
what matters is what looks like what
happened and what looks like what
happened
is pretty nasty his voice is amazing
that scene had me
I was laughing so hard my high star
water yeah yeah you really killed him
that was that was so funny
you guys are all a bunch of [__] okay
Chad your two BFFs are dead but do you
know how lucky you all are huh
what the f are you talking about man
there's no rules out here it's us
against them
no no there are rules you don't think
you can handle that
maybe you deserve to die
why is Chad so evil that's [__] up
yeah
check out the police come here come on
you guys let's go no you don't need the
cops oh my God this guy's awesome thing
what is he so afraid of maybe he's
running he's the one with the
inferiority complex oh God
climb in the back seat and we'll go have
a look
Chad's God Rogue this door had better
not charge me for this yep
oh look I'm gonna wedge it from that
side and you pull them out on three says
there no actual evil in this movie
Chad's evil
oh my God
no no do not try
[Laughter]
stop
this is my kind of stupid guy
oh [__]
this is bad you can't stay put
I'll handle this
is he gonna die good to see you again
yeah
we have had a doozy of a day all of a
sudden out of nowhere
these kids
started killing themselves all over my
property
you must think
some kind of a [__] believes story like
that no oh no no sir not morons
open-minded
you say you are just working when this
kid
ran up and stuffed his head into that
wood chipper yeah it is a fact and I
think maybe they might be trying to kill
the girl that we have
look you know what she can maybe explain
the whole thing if if uh if I hadn't
knocked her unconscious with a shovel
bedroom
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait wait where's it going
no no why would the cop not have his gun
out already I don't know now you're
looking at least two counts of
involuntary manslaughter officer do we
look like a couple psycho Killers to you
yes well it's
it's hard to say yeah
oh no you okay
oh [__]
oh my God
damn who directed this movie he takes
the gun
will fix the fiend I'm like who wrote it
oh you gotta take the safety off on the
side there
oh no oh my gosh
I love this River Chad what the [__]
you're something Dale I don't know none
of this would have happened if it wasn't
for you oh
let's save her oh let's save her well at
least she's still alive she's the only
one none of this would have happened if
we hadn't gone fishing
that isn't even an option I don't even
like this
what do you mean you don't like fishing
I mean
I like it okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry Tucker did I hurt
your feet the ultimate betrayal I'm
sorry
no don't let the dog get shot
did you bring that nail gun in here yeah
why
stay low stay low to the ground keep
your head not to roll
challenge kids
where'd the Dog go
oh you like that college kids how's that
tasting I'll play more where that came
from a bunch of freaks
they are a bunch of freaks bring out the
girl I'm gonna shoot your dog
[Music]
no college kids are faster except he
uses his uh inhaler that's good good
attention and detail he caught him
oh no this is taking a dramatic turn
he's awake
he's like why are you guys doing this
what the hell is wrong with you kids
payback time hillbilly stay back for
what
it's for Mike no
oh no but what'd he do did he cut off
his hand oh did he I don't know it was a
weird shot I couldn't tell
we heard the acts and then test
audiences didn't respond well to
actually seeing the violence I thought
it was his ear he cut off
your gas as good as mine
but I think my guess is better
it's good to cry sometimes
Allison you need to get out there she
needs to get out there and talk to them
man they don't know what's happening
they think that they're trying to kill
her I know she should go out there and
explain it she hasn't told her
well
it's hard to say
um your friends
do some of your friends take medication
yeah first I thought they were trying to
kill you and then they started killing
themselves and then
[Music]
the love is concept nobody wants to hurt
you it sure sounds like someone does I'm
gonna go talk to them okay say your idea
oh my God
oh no
they chopped off what
hand right
oh it's kind of small for a hand are you
a finger
I think it could fit there that's from
Tucker's shirt
what is that
uh I gotta go help Tucker God damn it
my best friend needs me I'm gonna get
these kids
they must have thought that you're
trying to harm me oh and why would they
think that
I don't know
I think you do know oh I thought that I
looked like some kind of freak
we mistjudged you Dale I there's a
message I'm really sorry don't judge a
book by its cover
that was the dumbest most amazing
goddamn stupid college kids
[Laughter]
Tucker
please no way
oh I never thought I'd say this but I'm
glad I'm not hunting like a bear
sorry about that
I haven't done anything to me Chad this
has all been a huge misunderstanding we
have to burn this place to the ground
no no no no no no Chad chat gasoline
games over there no tap no chat stop
stop wait a minute I remember reading
about this in my Sociology class I don't
think it's stock Stockholm has been
kidnapped ends up falling in love with
their kidnapper that's one way to find
love
I'll try it next to you let the girl go
you okay Ali did he just call you Ally
wait
I make some tea and and we all sit and
and talk this out oh yeah it sounds like
a good idea I'll provide the figure
sandwiches finger soon
is that chamomile tea because I kind of
have that it [__] with my asthma
[Laughter]
no asthma's gonna come back again I want
you each to tell your side of the story
see yourself in their shoes
okay not bad not bad understand each
other's perspective before any progress
can be made you have a career Chad why
don't you start
well where should I begin wherever you'd
like
before I was born okay maybe not that
far
important
you see my parents
Hillbillies just like him
my mother ran for a life oh she was the
only Survivor no I think maybe he's the
only person who lived is he there it was
before he was born no how would he be
born then
[Laughter]
well they torture
oh that's cruel she fought back and she
escaped good cop but my father wasn't so
lucky
generally horrifying yeah and a good
reason to not like some people I guess
my mom
Chad said they would go longer than 15
minutes we come in guns blazing
woman don't argue with me yeah woman are
they drinking tea
I would totally love a cup of tea right
now same sorry we don't provide that
here at the real reject Studio
it's cold it's just how I like it it's
your turn um
okay okay well but you got Dale first of
all I'm really sorry that your family
got massacred yes that's awful
that's right that's the lesson I can't
even hurt fish that's right
you can't even hurt a fish
so now that you've both expressed your
side of the story did they
I feel I feel better I feel neither
talked about the story
[Music]
my God no
oh
nice go back to hell where you belong
freak
oh no and all the gasoline
oh [__] you wanted to smoke a cigarette
but they worked so hard for their
vacation home I know
goddamn college kids
[Music]
oh my God her face
[__] Kevin I'm so sad
I'm a terrible therapist what
I thought you did a great job in there
really yeah really
oh he's gonna come out smoke is not good
for somebody with asthma though ah yes
good catch I think that we should go to
the pickup truck right now wait wait
should help him oh
never mind
[Laughter]
this this is
[Music]
I'm so upset about the house
understandable how he's gonna hit a tree
he's gonna hit a tree
what is happening to our protagonist
well Alan tudik said be careful with
this it's the only thing I had left so
you knew they were gonna crash it I
never should have talked to Allison he
were right
people like me and people like her just
don't mix it's not true that's not what
he said do you remember when we was a
kid
and we used to go catch frogs down at
that Creek so maybe Brothers remember
our Lifeline how we used to compete to
see who could catch more yeah I don't
think now is the time to talk about
Tucker I didn't let you catch more you
caught him on your own it was quicker
than I was come on Tucker no way you're
better than you think you are
that girl sees it
I've seen the way that the
two of you look at each other really
sees you for who you are
oh so maybe after this is all done
you two can
on a date cue the music I wanted more
negativity
strong and you're not as ugly as you
think you are
that means a lot coming from you he's so
cute both of them are so sweet I know
she needs you now more than ever
especially because you always falling
down and hitting her head
first rare best friends forever they're
just friends okay we figured it out
sometimes siblings are friends
thank you
that hurt very much breathing
out through your mouth oh my God go get
her it's so cute do me a favor anything
kick the [__] out of that little College
[__] for me would you yeah can you
stay here okay come on let's go
wow this movie is really good I know
he probably shot it on the cheap cheap
it's got heart it's goofy so much heart
it's so clever too yeah clever and it
riffs on the genre in such a unique way
you
what is happening now I'm willing to
forgive you but you're gonna have to
package
I was just not a very nice apology kiss
es we're making up he's so crispy
ah
sorry
that's gross he's so crunchy what are
these adjectives you have chosen for me
so crispy and crunchy don't you feel
like his skin is like charred yeah
oh my God now he gets the dress up
the real Iron Man
[Music]
you you want to help me here oh yeah
hang on
hang on her outfit is the biggest
mystery of the whole thing like I'm
supposed to believe those are one of
those guys pants you never know man
could have been like pants goals you
know
he's from the betrayed me Allison
no
can't kill Allison
[Music]
no okay okay
where did he come from
[Music]
oh
nicely done Dale
they actually kill her off no no way
zero percent chance
yeah he gives it to her was that
intentional holy crap it's time for you
to feel my pain bring it frat [__]
bring it frat [__]
she has no butt crack why are you
judging her not jealous the lack of that
butt crack
what come here and look at this his
parents are the ones who actually killed
everybody look at the guy in the middle
oh yeah he said his mother was captured
my father's body was never found I think
we first found him
oh
that's your real father no
no it's true Chad you're half hillbilly
he lied to me
oh goodness to protect you
[Music]
reaction in rare cases where people are
allergic to it
but he'll be okay as long as we get him
his inhaler
[Music]
get him his inhaler
you know she's good yeah she's very good
I just remember her on 30 Rock I thought
she was there to be pretty she's
actually like really good here I just
saw her in this movie sex drive she's
getting it yeah I wonder what what she's
been up to recently she has a ton of
credits hey buddy how you feeling
I'm feeling
high on prescription medication yeah
they found my fingers
check it out
I remember that one looking that way
they look funny to you
no no not really
it's a big beauty
that Andy straw your favorite sipping
utensil yum bigger out of a straw did
you ask her out for God's sake oh
well yes he did I never actually got the
chance so
no but you're hopeless yeah
you're probably right about that
except for yep she's a pretty darn good
bowler so
we're going bowling
you little [__] I'm out of here
[Music]
ow
she is a good bowler that girl has got
an amazing shot bowling fingers I know
you have to go after what you want
because it sure is heck fire ain't just
gonna fall right into your lap and just
be yourself okay yeah
oh my gosh do you know what that is yes
it's a
it's a helmet
Ah that's a cute gift it's perfect
so listen Dale I'm uh I'm really sorry
about everything that happened do you
think they'll kiss I hope so just you
know what let me just let me just say
this because I don't know if we're ever
gonna get to spend this kind of time
together again yeah
I just want to let you know
I see it
I'm like in love with him
really yeah really
[Music]
oh my God
should we go help her hell no it's just
happened he went after what he wanted
and who knows
whatever
[Music]
it's really creepy I don't know Craig
yeah you know me like Craig
yeah come on he like Craig
sounds like he's part of my tribe but I
don't know who it is wow that was really
really good all right Roxy take it away
what did you think of the movie really
surprisingly good not surprising because
you had told me that it was good but
surprising that I've never heard of this
movie and it feels like it should be up
there with some of those
mid-2000s comedies yeah it's a solid
horror comedy it's like does both so
well mm-hmm
yeah definitely but like even it's like
less horror and more comedy than even
like a scary movie kind of thing I think
maybe equal really I feel like it's
definitely scary movies this is Gory I
guess I think they did a great job on
really committing to the like the it
wouldn't be as funny if it wasn't as
violent yeah totally the like massive
angle of it yeah we got to say the word
on a live on YouTube oh the on the mass
unalived yeah they unalived themselves
they did it though it was just all by
accident that's just like the funny part
yeah because easily this could have been
a movie in which they were the bad guys
and whatever but the fact that it was
all like coincidence sake that was
really clever yeah and it had this like
sweet heart I really did because like
there's been like a couple of movies I
watched like Daredevil again here on the
channel because I had a similar
experience where I was like I don't
remember this I'm gonna watch it but I
was like once in a while something would
pop up and Daredevil that would go oh
yeah and I I remember the scene I didn't
remember any of this movie really wow I
think it was just two too big yeah well
this would be a perfect movie to watch
while you're like that because it's
funny as hell I know I remembered going
that was funny yeah but I don't remember
like Jack about the actual movie it's so
strange that we really liked so many of
these actors and we haven't and and
they've all seems like they've all
worked but that they like none of them
blew up other than Alan Tudyk I guess
well I imagine this is more of the cult
hit because I watched this on I don't
remember when I first watched this I
must it was like on some random stream
it might have been Netflix or something
uh way back in the day and it was just a
random thing I put on when I was like
binging horror movies so I didn't even
know I was like going into a horror
comedy
I think
whatever my memory tells me regardless
yeah you're right though like these
actors were so good even even the Chad
character yeah he's really good he I
loved how he and they all knew the kind
of tone and genre they were in the whole
time you need like the whole cast on the
on the right wavelength and I think they
all found that like no one tipped the
access point too much I thought this was
really well executed what was the
impetus for this today like did you see
it pop up somewhere are people talking
about this right now nice impetus oh
good choice of words super smart damn
that you know actually I'm more like
Dale I don't I don't know how smart I am
but I do remember words oh seriously for
the impetus I don't even know what that
word means what was the like reasoning
behind what was the thing
my Yusuf in a sentence I have eventually
figured it out
um but uh I don't know it was it was one
of the things on my list that I came
across it on the streaming I was like
like I said for years I just keep going
I should re-watch this because I I don't
remember anything about it and decide I
just wanted to watch it I think we've
had a couple of recommend I think
someone recommended it when we did
Jennifer's Body and that and that was
what made me add it to the list of like
yeah I really do want to watch that
again that one leans more horror this
one is like I would call this it was a
straight up comedy it was straight it
was sharp yeah it's like a sharp comedy
um because the the beginning part of it
I'm like okay there's something about
the grimy aesthetic that's a little
off-putting then you realize how
the budget is very it feels purposeful
they lean into it it doesn't try to mask
its budget like it actually helps
elevate it the fact that it's so low
budget and it has that kind of grimy
scuzzy quality to it because it's the
kind of genre of like the the old school
like Texas Chainsaw Massacre or Friday
the 13th movies that had that kind of
film grain
totaliness to it and and I thought they
did such a good job of like it's it's
it's a it's really smart it's smart
because like the character it's got the
kind of dumb comedy in the sense of like
these characters
are are a little dumb sure but it's
smart dumb comedy to me and I thought
they did such a great job on hopping
back and forth between the perspectives
of
you get why Tucker and Dale view the
situation this way and you get why the
college kids view the situation this way
and the way they because and I love how
it they do have this like sense the
sensibility about communication at its
core and that being the detriment to
what landed them all in the situation
because they all judged each other to us
it's surprisingly smart instead of just
gags you know yeah I think that both you
and I as writers like we're picking up
on the fact that they really put a ton
into like planting those seeds and also
like you said dealing with the budget
that they had there's like almost no
extras in this it almost entirely takes
place in one location or like one
Campground kind of thing
um we've got a limited cast that are
there and then they use the same type of
like anything we're using the whoop
chipper for that's also going to be a
death if there's a bunch of trees around
that's gonna be multiple deaths we know
if there's water that's going to be on
issue like they really use their
environment in this yeah I in such a
cool way that was that was really
surprising the ending was a Bizarro
moment but I think we're just gonna let
that go
yeah there's a bit of uh above Macabre
Huber to it it was really a dark keyword
in in that moment I was like I don't
know what's happening or is he just
kidnapping this girl maybe the message
is like yes you should go after what you
want but like maybe that advice doesn't
work for all people because some people
are creeps there are some actual creepy
Hillbillies out there who need to be
stopped yeah what did you think about
the reveal about uh who is his daddy was
Luke I am your father uh I thought that
was I thought that was funny it was it
was handled in a way that because the
mystery is not like the most engaging
part about it uh but they I I like that
they cared to put some TLC towards the
the mystery yeah totally and the the
you're half Hill
they played they played it so straight
yeah their delivery on it they really
believe what they're saying at least you
know it's like it's a great act it's
just great acting like they really
believe what they're saying and that's
what made it so funny like I never felt
I feel like nowadays it's gonna sound
like a total insult it is uh is that if
they'd made this movie like today like
just 10 plus years from now right
I feel like it would just be like social
media actors they would cast in like
people who were like famous on Tick Tock
or whatever influencers influencers is
what you mean by social media actor yes
that is that's correct impetus
absolutely not
um yeah I know what you mean the the
alley Katrina Bowden was so Earnest is
it Bowden or boating Bowden I don't know
b-o-w-d-e-n so Bo then maybe
uh for some reason I think it's about it
maybe that's because I used to date
somebody with the last name about it um
what happened there
this is a very very but a bummer I
messed it up I'm sorry yeah thanks I
reached out a few years ago he didn't
know oh really I'm sorry
I was like hey maybe he'll see this
video
kind of don't think so what's up friend
um sorry yeah I know I'll never move on
I sounds like a great guy
yeah I totally agree
anyway
yeah no he he essentially was Dale oh
really like interpersonality wise or
physical wise both neither
it's like a six foot blotting for the
white guy
he was a frat guy so maybe he's more
like Chad yeah he's the problem anyway
there you go yeah it was good it's good
to open up about these things on camera
yeah anyway
bowdance so yeah Katrina photos anyway
she's super early she's good yeah she's
really really good in there this is a
good word for it yeah and if she wasn't
it would have sucked
that's true I mean I I I've seen all of
30 Rock on another show I'm like I've
seen all of it don't really remember it
but my associate my memory with things
is often
like I remember how I felt about it I
don't remember me too that's what I
always say I don't remember plot points
in a movie but I remember how it made me
feel yeah and and I remember her
character in that show just essentially
just being there to be pretty and I
don't remember ever her actually
standing out and unless I'm remembering
that wrong
because here I was like oh she's
actually like
there's a sincerity to her performance
that feels very believable she was like
ditzier on the show right yeah she was
more like pretty blonde itsy girl like
she's the the model character and then
here she's
she's so much more than that and she's
believable yeah very believable and a
perfect the perfect energy balance uh
for the characters of Tucker and Dale I
hope they get married I hope so too
Tucker and their chemistry is so solid
those they have like amazing chemistry
too the to the point where we thought
there might be siblings even though they
look nothing alike oh that's not who
you're talking about now yeah yeah
Tucker yeah okay
you know they're actors they I mean
people who don't they don't I don't
think David Schwimmer and Courtney Cox
look alike
kind of do you really well I'm just
saying these actors they weren't
brothers so they need to look alike but
yeah siblings don't look alike all the
time I'm just saying we didn't think
that they were siblings because all of a
sudden they're on screen and we're like
oh they're identical we thought they're
certain things they had such great
chemistry yeah that's a fair point
did I get you defensive I'm sorry about
David Shore and Courtney Fox yeah
thing yeah I'm pissed
yeah it's just a really stand up for my
friends Courtney Cox and um David
Schumer are both like brunettes yeah
that's true
that's all it takes
similarities David Henry and Selena
Gomez and what is the Waverly Place or
siblings in that show
and and they don't look alike or they do
they don't oh I mean he's like pure
white oh he's like the whitest kid your
bread Pure White the best white but they
also are both brunette yeah so
it works casting wise
um I never thought about that that's
funny and uh yeah and this and uh I
think the wrestling Ensemble was fine
too you know like the physical gag bits
I think I love that wood chipper moment
so much because you saw it coming you
were like oh it's all but I think the
way they that's what I loved about it's
like the way they executed it because
they make it so obvious like they're
telling the audience he's going to die
like he's going to jump into somehow
he's going to land in the wood chipper
right and
I think your mind goes down like oh he's
gonna like trip into it or something
yeah he just like straight dives into it
totally as if it was a purpose is that
if it was purposeful and so they totally
surprised me and how and how he gets
into the wood chipper imagine how
shocked you would be if you were
bloating wood into a wood chip or you
ducked down to load would you go back up
and there's legs yeah and he tried
saving him too are you okay yeah I love
the escalation of their performances
this movie had a lot of heart and more
it had just the right amount of like
nuanced sensibility to not make it
because this is the kind of plot that
could have worn thin too early on even
for a short movie I hear you who do you
feel like you'd recommend this to like
people who love what movie oh boy
um like did you think that this is for
the like
super bad Step Brothers group of people
or is it for the people who love
um scary movie or is it for people who
love Friday the 13th and loves like I
think I think yeah like the horror crowd
would like this movie a lot I think
people who if we're talking about I
think this is more of the spoof uh
category even though it's not full spoof
but it's it's like right there so it's
like the Edgar Wright spoof level in a
way where it's not only being a spoof
it's just it's being its own movie with
characters and everything whereas like
scary movie is
I would call that a parody movie you
know and where this is it does spoof on
the genre but it decides to extend
beyond that and I think that's what was
so impressive about it we're talking so
serious about this comedy and I love it
because I respect this movie for what it
did
I have a lot of respect for this film
respect I really wish I could go watch
more of the director and Writer's work
I don't know what happened I think this
might have been one of those memories
that became a cold hit over time and so
yeah you just kind of don't generate
work when it came out you think that
people aren't talking about it I don't
remember because it was kind of before I
was in the space you haven't even the
space of what like this what we're doing
right now
that's the only reason you ever heard of
this movie
no I'm saying I wasn't that what no in
2010 I just wasn't really in the movie
space like I was not like paying
attention to what was out there and
things like that oh so you before you
were doing this you were actually
not as you just you just weren't because
I was always like kind of obsessed with
knowing about stuff even before I
started doing I'm a die-hard television
person got it I always have been and
then and always saw like the big
tentpole movies and and I did love
movies but something like this that
you're saying maybe was didn't catch on
till later there's a lot of stuff right
around this time period like 2008 9 10
11. right yeah if it was a deeper cut I
probably didn't hear it no you you
didn't you didn't even hear about this
that's what I find so surprising like
I've I've heard this in the conversation
I'm pretty sure it was recommended to
specifically us you grew up watching
cult movies not a lot I was uh what kind
of would horror a little bit more
um and you heard of this at the time I
had heard about Tucker and Dale Versus
Evil being good I did not know it was a
horror I didn't know it was a comedy
horror film I thought it was gonna be
more of a horror film
um for [__] yeah yeah well done uh
thank you I thought it would be more of
that but now this surprised me and I I
don't know thank you guys for the
recommendation yeah thanks everyone you
did it I'm glad you enjoyed it you
seemed like you enjoyed it yeah I
thought it was bomb it was awesome I
love when I watch movies here and then I
go and I tell all my friends like you
gotta go check out blah blah and then
watch my reaction And subscribe to the
real rejects yeah that's exactly what I
say hey you start getting tagged and
[__] now that's dope I saw that I've
been seeing that on Twitter and stuff
yep listen what did I tell you I grow on
beautiful like a fungus what did I tell
you I'm a fun game you're the fun guy
you're the fun guy they call me the fun
girl fun girl fun girl
[Music]
maybe it could happen a girl a girl can
dream one day when you and koi and
Michael start buying actual real rejects
or I'll just hook you guys up what who
looks more like David Schwimmer and
Courtney Cox or me and you
what what the hell did you just say what
is it what is your question
who looks more alike
you and I are or David Schwimmer and
Courtney Cox
ah
you know a lot of people think have
mistaken me for being Jewish for my
whole life really I could see it
really yeah I can see it too yeah I
could see it
a lot of people have mistaken me for not
being Jewish
um anyway anyway
now that we're here let's send this guys
thank you so much for being here uh you
could follow rocks in the world girls
totally forgot to promote that at the
beginning of this also uh subscribe and
uh you check us on patreon and hey uh
Roxy can you help me in this the patron
of the day shout out
um all right I wonder
what do you got who do you got well you
know I tell you before I used to say
grown people like a fungus yeah yeah I
would say grown people like us
mother bleach and then I heard that they
suck on people Mark Leach everyone
oh the way to pick that yes um oh hi
Mark
you know try should I pull out whatever
you can no I'm shouting on Mark because
a that was a room reference B e um you
can suck on us anytime
you heard me Mark Leach see you've got a
dope name and our dope Patron and super
sexy that was d a b c d
um and this smile is for you oh that's
really sweet
I know I've gotta know Mark pretty well
actually okay tell me more tell me more
did he get very fun he's from UK he's
had kind of a crazy year ooh he's had a
crazy year you know I love sometimes we
talk about our struggles he's had some
pretty crazy struggles okay well then he
really deserved this smile yeah he did
and he deserves something really
positive like what you dispelled his way
because yeah dispelled look at who's
bringing the vocab now ah honestly I
question if I used it correct I don't
know
sometimes I say words and I wait for the
other person to be like a little nod I'm
like okay I guess I used it right it's
not my thing yeah that's why I write
because I have a thesaurus ready if I
disposal at any moment
um but Mark my dude I really feel like
this year is going to be a big
turnaround for you I feel like there's a
lot of positive energy coming your way
yep I can feel it too and I appreciate
you for being a massive support in our
lives for so long and you know what dude
you are you you he has he's a he has a
really gentle heart okay well this one's
for you then Mark my your name is Mark
you should enjoy the park
because you're not an arc and that is
far
Squad Stark Tony you're our own Tony
style there you go
foreign
[Music]